[Music]
hey folks it's the matinee show first
movie we're gonna be talking about this
week just dropped on Netflix I believe
just on April 24th this is a kind of an
action movie yeah
from 2020 called extraction yeah it is
trend in number one and it's good it's
good I liked it very much it had a lot
of different elements all mixed in
together you got a guy he's uh he's a
combat he's an Australian guys combat
veteran and he's he's a contractor at
this point he's after his career I guess
and he's uh he rescues people I guess he
assassinates people and just does
mission yes whatever you build whatever
you pay him to do and this one he's got
a rescue the son of a drug lord has
captured by another drug lord now these
drug gangs happen in between India and
Pakistan so most of the shit's going
down inside either India Pakistan
Bangladesh
yes Bangladesh not Pakistan India and
Bangladesh and man it looks like [ __ ]
Bangladesh it's just you know I mean
it's words filled they did they did
shoot a lot of it in Bangladesh I think
a lot of the like smaller scenes chase
stuff I think they shot that in Thailand
but um a lot of the distance shots and
stuff were actually shot in Bangladesh
yes so it's mostly shot where it was
said I enjoy the movie I just can't find
anything wrong with it I thought there's
a bunch like John wick style gun kata in
there and I tell you you know you tried
that [ __ ] real life life you just get
[ __ ] mowed down you know you just
that just doesn't happen but it looks
good on camera well yeah it looks very
good on camera
combat doesn't take place at 5 feet does
it but yeah so chris hemsworth is in
this and he also produced it now this
was I didn't realize when we were
watching it but it was directed by Sam
Hargrave who was a stunt man and a stunt
coordinator on several of the Marvel
movies this is actually I believe this
is the first movie that he's directed
now this was written and produced by the
Russo brothers who actually directed
Avengers endgame among other things so
these are kind of like you know big
heavy hitter type of guys you can tell
that this is definitely a stunt man's
movie because like a lot of the stunts
much like John wick are done practically
I didn't really see a lot of CGI I mean
maybe it maybe there was some they did a
good job of hiding it there's a scene
where a woman shoots down a helicopter
with an RPG and it looked real
it really did it was [ __ ] I think in
reality you know it's a helicopter on a
crane and they just need the crane and
the wires out which is what they usually
do in a practical effect the way it was
done it looked good a lot of car chases
car wrecks running people over yeah
people getting hit by cars yeah a flake
falling out of buildings and [ __ ] like
that yeah lots of cool guns lots of cool
different military guys and gangsters
and [ __ ] and it's a bunch of [ __ ]
battles of Honor and you know just it's
a good movie I liked it yeah it was
based on a I guess it's based on like a
comic book and I kind of feel like they
maybe are trying to go like the
franchise round with this man you know
you don't have to UM because it does
seem like you know it could go either
way the ending the binding is they're
gonna add their Telegraph they did like
leave a little bit of an ambiguity there
at the end
Connor has an element of the old movie
called the professional where you had a
hits a little bit like daddy's you see
protecting a boy everybody's like a
moral gray area it doesn't like I really
liked um I mean mostly it seems like
most of the reviews I've seen of this
have been like you know the action
set-pieces amazing this don't work
amazing a lot of the cinematography is
really good
several like I know all the story and
characterization we're a little but you
know what I mean I didn't really find
that I was actually really I mean Chris
Hemsworth plays a very stoic character
um and at first it's kind of he's very
hard to read and stuff like that because
he's just like this stone-cold badass
who goes and does these jobs some of
which are very questionable and he's
kind of gotten used to that so that's
kind of what his character is but as the
movie goes on you find out you know why
he's like that and why he's ended up at
this place in his life that he's at you
know what I mean like he has kind of a
tragic backstory and also I kind of like
the relationship that develops between
him and the kid of the drug lord that
kid is great I really liked it a lot
like that you know it's it's like they
don't do a lot of like conversation
stuff because it's a pretty
fast-paced and that was the Russian
movie that was the right decision that
yeah wasn't a lot of conversation but
the little bits of conversation that
they had were that's enough that's
enough and it's like you got enough of
the gist you know there was like some
funny not funny like zany but like just
some kind of good dialogue between the
two of them well it's kind of like Mad
Max fury road there's not a lot of
dialogue in it it's just enough let you
know who the people are yeah you don't
need it if they're not having a quote a
scene yeah scenes only happen in movies
in real life it's just people talking
when they have to yeah and I like that
and that's essentially what this is
because they're just pretty much on the
move the whole entire time because he's
trying to like save this kid for you and
there's like all these like conflicting
for there's a time where he's you know
putting doing first aid on himself you
know that there's a time for them to
have a little conversation and and that
seemed natural and then you find out
more about the kid and that's fine
that's you don't need to know any more
about the kid they did they did it was
just enough and not too much so I think
think the balance on that was perfect
I thought so as well like you didn't
really I mean like I said you got the
gist of it yeah and the end what's his
name Christopher with movies any worth
yeah what's name the character Tyler
rape Tyler break that's right yes
Raik doesn't say much and I think that's
good the less these kind of guys say
that better well it that's it I mean in
real life if you were that person you
know time to talk about it you wouldn't
have time to talk about that [ __ ] and he
was like he had done a bunch of these
types of jobs before you know he was a
you know yeah he was a combat veteran I
think he said he'd done three tours in
Afghanistan at one point I think he'd
mentioned that um but since then he'd
been working for essentially like a
black market type of mercenary company
who just you whoever pays them in this
case like a drug dealers paying them hey
this rival drug dealer so I didn't ask
my kid so go in there and get him back
out so that's pretty much what he's
doing and he you know Tyler admits that
he has like you've been hired to kill
people so he's an assassin as well yeah
I guess you that probably happens a lot
depends on what country you're talking
about yeah who the client is right if
the client is an authority in that
country then it's with Thor if they have
enough money
right circumvent or if this the laws as
in this case nothing on the law yeah
well yeah that's what I met then
sometimes the threat is there and if
probably if the contractor can justify
go yeah that is a bad guy I'll get him
for you
yeah you know then that's what you do
because some some countries don't have
much of a government right you know so
you it all has to be done privately so I
couldn't understand that but yeah I
liked it it's if you like the new James
Bond type movies you'd like it if you
like the Mission Impossible it's kind of
like yeah this guy it gave me a little
bit of that vibe is impossible like that
like John wick but not as stylized not a
stylized or stylish still good some of
the John wick style close combat [ __ ] I
like it it looks great on camera to
watch it I've seen Reeves shoot Krita
[ __ ] Kenny Reeves it can shoot he
shoots well he's fast he's accurate
that's not [ __ ] totally tactical you
don't do that [ __ ] out in the open well
yeah a movie you know that's the only
thing that kind of gets me he's got one
dude he's got his holding one dude
shooting this dude and then shooting I
saw the guy five feet away and then
their buddies run up to them from 40mm
meters away and then engage in that same
close combat
that's not how close combat does you
shoot this guy you shoot that guy and
their friends just 40 meters away just
open up on you and machine guns and just
cut you to ribbons that's what really
happens well yeah cuz you'd be dead
you're dead yeah it wouldn't run over
there why want to combat I'm not as much
distance between you and the opponent as
possible you want to really want it to
be [ __ ] single well iam shots that
really that's that's really the better
than sniping that's most ideal there is
close combat it's just not this fanciful
and it's [ __ ] in reality it's the
last-ditch it's something you want to
avoid if at all possible and it's almost
you're almost you're you're it's almost
suicide your your chances of survival in
the long run are very low though the
longer you do that the less of your less
chances you're survive your survival
goes down you know yeah but like I said
it's coming from these last wars that we
were in or mostly kind of more like law
enforcement where guys in a pcs and
nickels are going into houses to go find
some suspects and more like law
enforcement than war when I was in the
Army we didn't go into houses there's a
bad guy when to the house we just called
artillery fire too called helicopter
something look [ __ ] a whole house up I'm
not going in there yeah they want to get
me to God come out of woods and come
find me I'm walking to this gun barrel
yeah that's the last thing that you want
to do but I understand it is a movie
yeah every guy's cool [ __ ] they all got
again a frame and everybody want if you
want to actually love that [ __ ] I see
action I love that [ __ ] but it gets
translated into good what we call gun
tube which is all the gun channels on
YouTube and they [ __ ] start talking
about
that's what combats like and that's why
that is not you [ __ ] stop it never
been a military that is not the way it's
a lot that's not the way it is just
because you own an ar-15 and have all
these little lights less wit you it and
just because you're fast
that doesn't mean you wouldn't get the
[ __ ] shout out of you well Italy one
thing that I did like about this I mean
you know it's more I will say that
extraction is a more realistic movie
than John wick yeah I think some very
different movies but yeah it's a
different thing like I said John wick
movies you know I'm supposed to be
stylized movie guys reaction this one
was a little like you know grittier and
was trying to go more realistically try
to go more military right with every
action movie you know that that's not
how it would work in real life I think
probably every action movie ever made
yeah I don't think I've ever seen the
same and then Bob is a movie kind of
like this but he's a little more suave
[ __ ] assassins yeah he's working in
the shadows he's gonna talk his way
through it and even if I can do
something to you and then the American
version of that would be [ __ ] you
know Mission Impossible
I think Mission Impossible is probably
the closest to the mission although it
wasn't quite as slick but and I think
honestly I liked a lot of the stunt work
and the action set pieces in this one
better than some of the Mission
Impossible employees because like I said
they seemed more grounded in reality
whereas Mission Impossible kind of
mission ease make epic is American James
Bond yeah it's got to be bigger and
better it's American it's got to be more
bigger and better
yeah and that's what James Bond does the
dick thing it's a dick thing and they
got cruise which cruise can really shoot
real life yeah I respect cruise lot
people [ __ ] pick on him and [ __ ] but
the dude actually can't fly these
airplanes and these helicopters and
these second motorcycles and he can't
shoot so I really like that I really
like that he puts in the effort to not
be a fake but to really know how to do
that [ __ ] it does show in this movies I
like I really like that last was it fall
out yeah yeah it was good really good
and but like I said that is competing
more with James Bond yeah
so it's suits and nice [ __ ] and slicker
technologies this is military and this
is like everywhere in much like you know
Bangladesh in the crowded streets dirty
and it's yeah everything's very dirty
and you know you to climb it up in these
crumbling buildings and like shooting
people with [ __ ] RPGs and the bad
guys are just skinny little starving
kids sometimes he's beating them up [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] awesome yeah it's like so
what this is really really good I mean
the stunt work is incredible in US and a
lot of the action set-pieces like the
one where they were chasing each other
through the streets and all the driving
and they were like running people over
and and I mean [ __ ] Chris Hemsworth
you know he's in very good shape
obviously and he looked like he did a
lot of his own stunts and he gets pretty
beat up during this as you yeah I would
I did like stiffen getting sore and
[ __ ] all did take more damage than a
man could take a shake off within a 24
yes you can say that we got hit by a car
he jumped out of a [ __ ] car at about
60 fell out of building he got grazed a
couple times he got into a bunch of
[ __ ] fistfights all in one day yeah
and walk it wasn't it was a bad day and
he could walk the next morning when he
woke up yeah when I wrecked a [ __ ]
motorcycle when I said that motorcycle
down what was I like to the few hours
the next day he could even [ __ ] move
actually by the time I got home from
work you couldn't yeah I had I
distinctly remember he had forgotten
this cuz we were talking about this last
night I was going he was I said he's
like man I just got in a motorcycle
accident you didn't break any bones or
anything I had
mehran and everything came off about a
60 he's about 60 miles an hour he came
off the bike and he was okay like he
could get back home and everything but
by the time I got home from work like
maybe four or five hours later yeah he
was laying on the bed just going buddy
was [ __ ] I had to go to the
McDonald's drive-through and get him a
Big Mac and put it on his chest yeah my
pose off I know I was like trying to
take his [ __ ] socks off and his pants
are putting like sweatpants on you or
something like that you were just like
oh okay
I pissed blood a couple times yeah a
little bit of pinkish in there yeah they
went away I kept drinking water it went
away a few hours later sad news alright
but yeah I was bruised on [ __ ] one
whole side of my body couldn't even
[ __ ] move couldn't get my [ __ ]
shirt off I might so guys I got I got
experience he went through about it was
six times that yeah I don't think you've
oh I have to say to that
David Harbor from stranger things
obviously Heep hopper he had a cameo in
this I was a little more than a cameo it
was like he was kind of a like a long
scene in there so that was delightful to
see him and I you know I really liked
his character and I liked the
interaction he was like an old friend of
Tyler rakes and he was like went in for
help and all this horrible [ __ ] happen
but yeah this is like I can see why this
is the number one movie if you yeah if
you really like action movie like really
really kick-ass like stunts and all that
kind of [ __ ] then you definitely chose
its really fast paced it's like really
enjoyable not boring nothing it's just
like no I hope is the future for Netflix
and like direct to direct to [ __ ]
home you know streaming I hope the
movies are like this and I hope they can
be successful well I mean if this is
gonna it stays streaming like number one
and it's like it's really this is how
you have you learned everything then
they'll make more like it so that's what
you got to do yeah and it is left open
for a sequel I would like to see more of
these I I would as well yeah I think
that they could really expand his
character I think it was a direct
response to John wick I think yeah even
though like you said it's a totally
different like the look of it is
different
version of that yeah but yeah it's
definitely cool so it's on Netflix at
least in the US I don't know about other
countries but yeah definitely check it
out if you like action movies because it
was pretty [ __ ] great
you
so for the second movie that we watched
this week this is one that just dropped
on shudder out of kind of nowhere this
is called blood-quantum yeah it's good
when this is a zombie flicks not a bad
look quick but this was sabe versus
Indians which is kind of Indians as in
Native American yes not and as in people
from India yeah they're Northern Indians
later I believe they are supposed to be
Micmac Indians Magnus yes from northern
Quebec right we actually know a northern
Indian girl she's a Mac ha yeah Tori
yeah he's the cutest little punk rock
girl when she was a little girl and then
she's now she's kind of like this I
don't know
multicolored here God woman now goth
chick yeah yeah yeah and she kind of
looked like these people except she had
blue eyes yeah weird but you know yeah
enhanced can look like anything nowadays
yeah this is basically this is a cool
movie okay so it's kind of like an it it
had like um a Romero style premise in
the sense that it's like a zombie movie
and as gory and everything like that but
it also had kind of a little bit of a
social commentary type of thing going on
please don't walk in the yeah there's
her but okay well she but yeah so it was
written and directed by Jeff Barnaby and
like I said they they actually filmed
this in northern Quebec and I think in
New Brunswick and it's basically the
story of this zombie plague that they
have cut like the first act of the movie
like I guess like the first third is
just kind of saying how the plague kind
of came about establishing like all
these relationships between the
characters because there's like this
reservation or like town reservation
called a red crow and the sheriff who's
name is trailer and I think the actor's
name is Michael gray eyes and so it's
him and his
ex-wife and like his son by one mother
and a son by another mother and there's
all this family tension and [ __ ] so it's
this really small town and this zombie
plague starts which interestingly starts
with like the fish like fish and dogs
and stuff like that then they get it but
then like so they kind of established
that that's happening and then it like
jumps ahead like six months we're you
know pretty much the it seems like the
plague has kind of taken over the whole
earth however the you know the one thing
that's different about this is that
Native Americans are not immune to the
zombie plague but nobody else is yeah
yeah Europeans came here you know I mean
brought smallpox and stuff we yeah every
were kind of immune to it or had a
limited immunity but they weren't yeah
you know that was back in the 1500 s
when the Spaniards show up so why not
why wouldn't they possibly be immune to
something that you know I mean that that
we are not immune to yeah immunity was
always an issue it was a good take yeah
I mean you know I mean and I don't think
I've ever seen anything done I mean you
don't see a lot of movies with Native
American characters or you know pretty
much almost all of the characters are
Native American carriage there's a few
white ones in there but so they can be
eaten but if they get bitten they don't
turn yeah they can get bit and obviously
the zombies if they're if enough of them
pile on you would eat you then obviously
you're gonna die then but yeah if they
get better they won't turn so this kind
of like throws a different dynamic into
the situation now think about it if
you're mostly a bunch of Native
Americans inside a compound who are you
worried about turning into a zombie just
the white people yeah and you already
kind of don't like the white people
right all this kind of like racism going
on yeah because like all these white
people keep turning up video compound
and like wanting he'll want and they're
like get these [ __ ] out of here yeah
and they bring up a lot of stuff about
you know these white people are so
civilized they can't take care of
themselves you know the truth to it you
know I mean these they were mostly you
know like soccer moms and dads and [ __ ]
yeah but these guys are tough they're
hardcore one of them is a world war ii
veteran and he's got to capture japanese
sword he got off the
japanese during an island campaign and
he's you know he's an old guy but he's
like a badass
yeah kills a bunch of them with a sword
one of things I liked about it is that
it kind of had it kind of had a certain
effect that they were using that you saw
in Mandy that that's when when [ __ ] got
real heavy they might show kind of like
an animated sequence yeah they
definitely seemed like they were washing
that it was really cool it was it only
happened a couple times like briefly
yeah but um yeah the animation was
really nice much like in Mandy there's
just those animated sequences and there
and it's it's it's trying to express
something that's happening in the spirit
world yeah you know like one of them is
kind of like shows you what's going on
the evil that's going on inside the
heart of one guy you see that yeah and
then another then when the the world war
ii veteran when he goes down he
sacrifices himself you know fighting a
horde of damn zombies he's killed but in
the spirit world he lives on he was
still fighting more of them yeah that's
pretty cool
and then before he goes out you know it
you start hearing in the background
chanting and here you hear his like
Indian death song coming yeah which I
liked all that [ __ ] all that all that
Native American stuff man [ __ ] it
really worked out well with the zombie
movie yeah cuz it's not a perfect movie
yeah but it's a good it's a good movie
yeah some of the acting is a little
questionable as some of the scenes are a
little dark and you can't like the way
they're edited you can't entirely see
what's going on but those are really
pretty minor nitpicks
if you like George Romero's stuff it's
almost kind of a combination of his
earlier stuff and his later stuff you
know like land of the dead
type period there's some really really
good some of the kills are off screen
but when they do show them it's like
pretty gory and over-the-top you know a
lot of the character dynamics like the
you know stuff between the characters is
really interesting I liked a lot of the
characters and [ __ ] like that so I liked
the movie I did too but what I didn't
like about it is that the the preamble
to the outbreak I think was a little too
long
yeah and it was also a little too wordy
it was too much focused on the
relationships of the characters it
should have been
trimmed down into mostly an
action-adventure movie yeah you don't
you didn't need to talk about the things
that they were talking about cuz in my
opinion yeah it's it bogged the movie
down it should have been constantly
rolling forward like a really good
Walking Dead episode should have been
like a Walking Dead double episode yeah
well sometimes and I think this happens
a lot when I don't know if this if this
writer director has made any movies
previous to the surface like his first
big one but um something a nice and I
see this in a lot of movies even by
experienced filmmakers where they'll
show something happening and then like
the next scene it'll show like
characters talking about which is hat
and I'm like you don't need to do that I
saw it yeah it's like I understand that
maybe the characters have to like
discuss it among themselves but you
don't need to like repeat which has
already been yes scene I can just assume
because it comes across like they're
trying to make filler like they like it
wasn't long enough yet yeah like like
they're trying to fill it out yeah you
know like they didn't have enough money
to throw in two or three extra action
scenes so they patted it out with
dialogue and yeah you don't need that
it's bet it this would have been a lot
better if it is remember the Japanese
zombie movie were supposed to be done in
one cut it was called one game one kind
of the day imagine that this was a one
cut tale yeah not made to look like a
one cut tail like that but serious with
these damn India's on a survival mission
yeah
with less dialogue because you don't
really need you didn't need all the
dialogue to know who these people were
yeah they showed us who they were yeah
that's what I mean it's like so so some
of it that you didn't need but like I
said it's a pretty minor nitpick this is
actually a pretty rad maybe like all the
gore was good I really liked a lot of
the characters there was like some kind
of dark humor in it a little bit yeah
left open for a sequel to yeah it's
possible that they could do one as I
said this premiered this actually you
know it says 2020 on shudder but it
actually premiered at the Toronto Film
Festival because it's a Canadian movie
in case I didn't mention it and I think
it got one of the runt runner-up
People's Choice Awards at there so it's
kind of gotten a little bit of buzz and
stuff also I wanted to say - I was
watching a guy earlier that
who is a Canadian film reviewer and he
really liked this movie but he was mad
because he's Canadian and he's like I
don't know why shudder premiered this on
American shudder but not on Canadian
shutter even though it's a Canadian
movie I wanted it'll have to do it has
to do with like whoever the distribution
because if he is just distribution
rights and different countries and [ __ ]
like that also before we wrap up this
particular movie I want to say that one
of the best things about the movie is
that it's only mentioned like a time or
two but there is apparently in the
universe of this movie there is a strip
club and it is called the fish Minton
yeah that's funny yet and I just I just
laughed my ass out of like is the strip
club is called the Fishman I'm like that
is fantastic oh it's one of my favorite
things about what I thought was cool
about this I thought the cast was
authentic looking well they all were
they only are actually and I was
impressed man they're [ __ ] big yeah
when I was in the Army you know a lot of
the Native American guys out that I
worked with were smaller guys but
evidently up north they got some big
[ __ ] Native American guys these were
some big somebody some of those dudes
look like above 6 feet and well it was
good because they look like they could
totally go and kick ass you know what I
mean which they do and like I said just
good Gore in this um you know little
dark in places so you can exactly tell
like especially like during some of the
bigger battle scenes like between Lezama
and whatnot but you know other than that
it's I I really liked it it's like a
different take on the zombie genre some
similar things you know to a Romero
flick or something like that but though
the whole Native American setting and
everything really gave it like kind of a
different feel which I really enjoyed
yes worth watching
but yeah it's on shudder so if you want
to check it out then I recommend it
you
that's right all right this one here man
disappointed me yeah well okay
now he's weird this one is called we
just found this one randomly while we
were scrolling through our Xbox rental
thing yeah this is a sci-fi horror movie
it's Australian it's called the dust
Walker yeah now the poster looked cool
cuz it looked like you know kind of
Lovecraftian was like the tentacles and
trailer was good the trailer looked
kick-ass yeah and actually for the first
probably third of the movie yeah it's
like this I was into it it almost seemed
like kind of a combination of tremors
invasion of the body snatchers it like
that type of vibe and a little bit of a
Lovecraftian type of thing I thought it
was gonna go like squirm yeah it was old
or like slither or something like that
yeah it had a little bit of that yes
form was that bad work as a bad one
starts off you're something going deep
through space like a [ __ ] Burton and
you see it point of view it's going
through space it comes into our galaxy
and then it impacts on the damn earth
and it leaves the [ __ ] well it comes
in like a meteor impacts on the earth
and he's a big like out in the [ __ ]
Australian outback yeah tiny little town
yeah big crater and then people see it
in Australia hidden but they don't see
where it actually goes and then they see
a UFO yeah so I guess a UFO was
following it yeah I didn't get that and
then like I was reading like a plot
synopsis of it later and this is
probably bad like I wasn't drunk or
anything watching this movie I had one
where he comes unintelligible yeah like
I didn't so I was reading this plot
synopsis and I was like oh the meteor
and the alien for like two two separate
things and it came and destroyed the
things that it let out okay yes I didn't
even harder on fire I didn't even pick
up on that but I thought it was all like
one thing it was badly meant badly
written and mismanaged the ideas I mean
they they had a good cast the acting was
pretty good this the location was really
good they had the makings of a very
interesting [ __ ] science fiction
movie and they [ __ ] it up by
overcomplicating it it kind of bum
me out because like I said the first
third of it I was really invested like I
liked all the characters it's basically
like small-town Australia and there's
like um you know Cher I guess she's
supposed to be the sheriff and that like
sheriff and her like deputy or whatever
and you know all the just this is a very
small town and there's not really that
many people there and every and like so
some of the people in the town like that
have touched this weird thing it's kind
of like color on a space and the way
that lady touch this thing that came in
look at red spores yeah and then they
start like acting really weird and like
killing their family members and like
they're just standing around staring at
people like invasion of the Body
Snatcher and I really dug like that and
I'm like god this is really quitting
when it never took it to the next level
yeah but it stayed idling like that yeah
and it had a [ __ ] good premise when
they first find it they find these
animals that look like they're blown up
with these red spores and like tentacles
looking they drown out of it yeah and I
was go this is gonna be pretty badass
and it what it first looked like what's
happening it looked like animals got
spores on them and if they ran up the
people and blew up because murky and
then this for then the Spurs go on
happen and I thought that person would
go and blow up and make the sport and
dad they were hoping for people to blow
up yeah and that would have been a good
[ __ ] story yeah that's the way I'd
have to work at that I thought that
that's what they were - snow ahem for
some reason the animals blew up but then
it got on the people but the people
could walk around and talk they would
kill other people but they were like
possessed kind of yeah and they could
hear people talking and then they wrote
they would but they would allow
themselves to be arrested which that
[ __ ] threw me off they didn't seem to
really die on their own and then this
[ __ ] big like dick scorpion comes out
of nowhere it looks like that's kind of
what a brother would call a crooked
[ __ ] with legs on the back and a
[ __ ] scorpions tail would have
[ __ ] bunch of teeth in the front of
it and you're like well what's the [ __ ]
is this thing and and and it wasn't
until later you find out that this is
like the cops I guess and it's trying to
stop this outbreak but the outbreak is
just a bunch of spores that make people
kill other people but it
really sure what the endgame was because
maybe if the meteor came maybe that
wasn't even like in intelligence it was
just like a natural phenomena I think it
wasn't natural like because didn't they
say something about ants and like
something a parasite to get an ant's and
start making him act crazy but there was
yet but there was all kinds of [ __ ] they
missed
they found the crater but they never
[ __ ] investigated the crater they
just found it they didn't look down in
the bottom nobody went down there on a
rope there's all kinds of [ __ ] that
could have happened you could have gone
down there and found a damn alien nest
or the person gets down there and got
infected and then they come back up blow
up this is Australian okay and Australia
has been [ __ ] hidden pretty heavy
lately I mean they make them pretty
kick-ass so I was really
I was really disappointed I was like
this has got a lot of promise but it's
just not [ __ ] delivering on this
crime I feel like you know what I do I
[ __ ] they could have done I feel like
this one almost seemed like they didn't
have the budget to do what they wanted
yes and they were trying to and they had
this like really big like epic idea they
didn't have the money to pull it off and
it really did seem like maybe they
didn't have they're like well we need to
like pad this out so it really did seem
like a lot of the running time was kind
of like the few residents of this tiny
town like kind of sneaking around like
trying to avoid yeah yeah other people
and it's unclear where they're going and
why yeah there's no real plan yeah is
that you're like okay they're trying to
no more bold they're trying to go
somewhere but they don't really [ __ ]
every now it's like they'd make an
offhand comment about oh well some of
the other residents are like trapped in
the diner or whatever they had to like
go get them but it's like it seemed like
a large part of the running time was
just them kind of like sneaking around
town and trying to avoid the people that
had already been taken over by the
spores yeah and then like I said when
the when the dick scorpion alien got
there the Cox Corp
started like sucking people up with the
tentacles yeah I'm thinking this is part
of the same boss I thought it was right
I thought it was all like that was part
of this was like I thought that the
spores were what he
sent out ahead of time to leave kill
everyone off and then they were gonna
come and take over I thought but
apparently they're not uh really or he
came and he was trying to like get rid
of the people that already had sport I
don't know it didn't make any difference
it because first of all the the caucus
or I'm called because it kind of looks
like a four-legged dinosaur and a
cricket the cave cricket with a scorpion
body we hear the score in anyway um the
caucus or what was I gonna [ __ ] say
about the yeah I got started by the
concept now I'm walking to caucus silver
I could use one of them anyway what
happened was is that the chard I take
the caucus or the [ __ ] central theme
of the movie I guess but the CG on it
sucked that never would have had the
caucus or I think that the budget really
kind of yet really what I think they
almost done you tell me we eat them
because you see I have another
hypothesis of what happened what's the
hypothesis that that there were that
there wasn't a story more about those
spores okay but for some and they shot a
bunch of stuff but for some reason that
didn't work so they say reenter in it
they reacted it and added the caucus
yeah yeah alright I think that caucus or
was added because they could not do
something else because that just felt
very unwieldly was that that felt like
that was something they were forced to
do maybe that would make that would make
a lot of sense and that and that would
make sense like why there was two
separate things yeah I don't believe the
caucus or was originally in the story in
the story I think what it was gonna be
and what it should have been is really
kind of about these alien spores that
infected this town out and [ __ ] near
the outback of Australia and what this
was gonna be as something kind of like
Carpenter's The Thing yeah
where they were trying to stop the
invasion of the bodies I got a very
invasion of the body snatchers kind of
thing and I really think
they should have just gone in that
direction with maybe not even a
malevolent alien but just this you know
it could have been like a John Wyndham
thing where there's just this remember
how Bork a member how they tried to
leave but they couldn't because the
roads were blocked by the [ __ ] I
don't know the wind [ __ ] well there was
a just storm in the dust storms women
drove through it Angela I think when a
machine just like teleported back into
the town like so it wasn't letting them
leave I was kind of like an unwieldly
way of doing what it what happened in
carpenters the thing where you couldn't
get off the dam right off the [ __ ]
dams South Pole that's what they're
talking about yeah they're going to
paint it but they just didn't have
they're trying to keep everybody
contained in this town by your story
because if you could stay out big yeah
cuz you can leave you would but the our
back is nothing like in terms of like
you know how remote it's nothing like
the South Pole it's now both remote as
[ __ ] okay and it's frozen so you can't
walk off of it but they've tried to do
that with the Outback that's what I
think originally what they were doing
yeah I like you said if indeed that is
the case that the that the alien you
know the dick scorpion a later the
caucus or it was that it was added later
because they thought because whoever it
was thought well it needs a monster or
it's not exciting look at how they lost
that thread the whole deal with the
spores I'm not know this is going good
well what happened today that's exactly
that's what I thought I thought that the
spores were gonna like start blowing
people up no it was gonna start like
disseminated right and like making
everybody crazy and then maybe grow into
something right unlikely and I was
thinking it was more like not like it
was put there by malevolent aliens
necessarily but it was just like a
natural thing that get him out of a
meteor I think it's like in [ __ ] in
the that Creepshow segment yeah I mean
the meteor came and started growing
plants all over right I think that's
originally what it was yeah which
probably would have worked that one but
I made them add this add the monster
yeah for some reason which it didn't
need no didn't need it should have just
been nothing about this outbreak of damn
spores and people blowing up into spores
and spore carriers and becoming kind of
like an ass infected with spores that
stress and the spores like that can you
kill your family and that's all
you need what the hell do you need to
add a damn caucus order this [ __ ] for a
bad CGI caucus or yeah you know and like
I said and I didn't really I got a
feelin that there were studio meddling
or something although I mean it's an
independent movie but maybe you know
maybe they ran out of money maybe they
ran out of money and they had to get
like some funding from some production
company or something and they said hey
put some monsters in yessir he will not
help he's but you like something
happened to well we're not gonna help
you with your movie unless a cop yeah
something like that it was some caucus
or bastes productions a caucus or yeah
we have to have a caucus or in every
single movie it's in the contract well
they have though that happened to have
to Edward a lot with your religious
people fun in this movies as well no we
have to have the Lord's message in here
somewhere
yeah so you know make it as trashy as
you want it you're saying oh that's bad
yeah that's bad and then you do some
bible quotes yeah have you judge
excoriating people at the end forgot him
amoral I got a feeling us what happened
to the caucus or it because maybe
because the design of that monster was
[ __ ] horrible horrible it was it
looked terrible
Hey look terrible which like I said it's
a real bummer because I mean for the
first third of this movie we were into
yeah we're like oh this would be good
cuz it seems like that you know the
whole all the actors I liked all the
characters I liked the concept like it
was really creepy like all the towns
folk just stare yeah and Australians you
know they're good-looking people they
got good-looking women they're better
looking at us i every time i see god
they had that cute redhead and then the
[ __ ] sheriff she was a female she was
cute and then [ __ ] you know i mean
it's just
yeah australia is gonna show you some
cute women that's what they get that's
what they do
yeah they got handsome handsome man they
gonna show you that too
did they show you the handsome man um I
guess I can't really remember I can't I
wasn't really trying to dissect the
[ __ ] well yeah I was like I said I'm a
writer I tried to die yet every after I
saw after they started locking up the
infected once and it got and it would go
inside the cell with him and talk to him
as safely and come back out I was like
this has not gone right well yeah
because then it really didn't seem like
a threat there's no correct
now yeah there's like and then these the
guys you can arrest them and talk to
them and then they don't blow up yeah
don't pull up in a red spores and a few
that's what I was kind of hoping would
happen yeah they went in there to that
cell to talk to him and he would just
blow up in this boy yeah everywhere and
it could hear voices they never really
resolved that yeah that was the shame I
think that like I said I think they had
like a really good idea but they didn't
have like the money to execute it the
way they wanted to maybe and um but I
mean the concept was good you don't need
the monster I would throw this movie
away and one day try to remake it yeah
Emily I try to associate the new the
movie this one cuz it's a great idea
great ideas I guess maybe this was what
they wanted but I got a feeling no I
don't think this would think it does
really the monster aspect did seem kind
of tacked up it was tacked on I think or
at least they over thought it and tried
to add to it doesn't make any [ __ ]
sense that is already a good enough
premise yeah but there are scenes
missing like you have a you have an
American girl at her whole job in the
movies to run around taking pictures of
things and find the damn hole in the
geologist I don't know but there should
have been a scene where they went down
into the damn crater and found some yeah
I feel like I said I bet they couldn't
appreciate something like that but
that's what had happened yeah you know I
mean if you're gonna [ __ ] write this
cheque you better cash it see I always
felt like when you're making an
independent because honestly um you know
some really good movies have been made
with like nothing budgets but I really
feel that you need to take your budget
in your location into account right and
then write a script from that like with
what you have so you don't need to like
have this big huge idea and you are not
going to be able to execute it the way
you want to and it's just gonna be much
better to get rid of the [ __ ] caucus
or and it made this a damn thing like
extraterrestrial infection kinda like
the Andromeda Strain
mixed with rabid yeah because that
wouldn't have been real difficulty
breathing making had been a lot better
yeah been a lot better oh yeah these are
simpler yeah simple and then you deliver
on that yeah to deliver on that promise
people with [ __ ] red spores blowing
up or red spores and they're kind of
like zombies
infected people from rabid yeah but they
can do they're not really a Xabi they
can talk maybe they hear maybe they have
a what do you call it you add [ __ ]
that's cheap like just give them
dialogue to make it look like that they
all have a communal hive mind
yeah like voiceover yeah just stuff like
that yeah and this movie would have been
[ __ ] awesome
yeah such a great idea with the great
with just a simple well executed premise
like that yes with the right action
scenes written yes I never really felt
these people were in danger did you no
not really no and like he's walking
around the street there's people
standing out there they run from him but
the thing is they're not a threat they
didn't have the balls to like kill a
little girl and like do some [ __ ] like
that so there was that aspect but yeah
it really didn't seem like anyone was in
any immediate danger because most look
at her flow you could see like the look
at his face that's it yeah but yeah just
it really did seem like you know yeah
the the infected people could run really
fast but they normally didn't they
usually just kind of stood there and
stared at you creepily I felt that much
of the movie was shot already and then
they had the fan they had that way they
and they couldn't fix it because they
already had footage that's what I think
happened it might have been yet but yeah
I mean yeah is it worth seeing no well
the first third of it is good yeah I
likes the first third of it but yeah
it's 399 for SD yeah and I only gave it
two stars and that's what other people
were giving it yeah was it cuz they
don't Lee you don't see the radio I
don't know yet to me it looks like a
movie that was gonna be good and then it
kind of just fixed it yeah something
happened to it they tried to just kind
of cobble it together and they put that
out little well yeah that's what it's at
least it's done
at least the movies done I think that's
what happened yeah I just have a feeling
of that much like I said that it was
something that was patched together and
try to salvage out of some footage that
they had yeah but like I said it's a
real shame cuz yeah I'm like a really
good movie but yeah
[Laughter]
you